who's watching the babies yeah
just with the family is still blue yeah
it's a lot of balogun with the family
and I didn't
do it just like I mean you guys know we
just had tension and fighting in Israel
and it's really lingered on so much more
than it needs to
Alex called us and he wants us to throw
a surprise party for Lauren I think it's
really sweet that Alex is stepping up
and being you know extra romantic and
extra making Lauren feel extra special
during this weird time that she's going
through
by the way I got an email and
I don't know if you're aware or not but
your sister and your mom rsvp'd no
we got
what is going on
Rona telling me that my mom and my
sister rsvp'd no to my baby shower
inside it definitely hurts I think it's
really up
I mean I think the the trying to make a
power move again and to prove some kind
of Point like that's what they've been
doing for the last couple of months I
don't know what they're trying to prove
but but that we need them so much we
can't move to Israel what
[Music]